SCP-682 Vs a Ton of Liquid Nitrogen.
After trying and failing to kill SCP-682 via
anomalous means, Dr. Carlson wished to return
to basics and try some non-anomalous murder
methods for bringing an end to this nasty
lizard.
The 682 tissue sample was successful.
It was frozen and shattered when struck with
a hammer, exactly as intended.
However, when 682-proper was doused with liquid
nitrogen, its body remained frozen and dormant…
For about ten minutes.
Then, it began increasing its body temperature
until it was thawed.
But it didn’t stop there.
It kept increasing its body temperature until
it was so hot that the walls of its containment
chamber began to melt.
Dr. Carlson noted, “Interesting, it retained
the adaption even after it was no longer necessary.
Maybe we should be more careful.”